the question with any technology that
has both tremendous benefits and
potential large risks is when and where
are you going to apply it when do the
benefits outweigh the costs I find it
deeply ironic that a country that was
largely populated by people who are
willing to try a new thing and basically
gave up everything they had to try some
new thing to find a better life that 100
200 300 years later we're suddenly
becoming timid we're still on that
journey to find a better life I think
one of the great advantages of our
society is we can empower everyone but
especially kids to actually make a
positive contribution figure out a way
to try out new technologies in a
decentralized small-scale way right now
the Internet has brought everybody
together that means we all swim or sink
together maybe it might make sense to
break up communities or find some way to
foster it's sort of experiments
hello and welcome back well I'm somewhat
sad to say we've reached the very final
session of the entire conference the tea
the theme of this final session is a
theme that's near and dear to my heart
agency and empowerment and what's
interesting about those two rural words
is the duality that we face in the ways
that artificial intelligence and
computational technologies have pushed
in both directions on both agency and
empowerment we all know the ways in
which computational tools have actually
increased people's sense of empowerment
their reach their knowledge level the
Willey the ability that they have to
push on the world at the same time as
they have empowered people we also all
know from many books that are out and
many economic debates that in fact
automation technologies have also
disempowered people by creating
underemployment crises in specific job
sectors and so we also know that the
very same technologies that empower us
and give us a sense of personal agency
can disempower us and to add to that
layer cake one third and final layer in
fact these automation technologies can
act in such ways that we infer upon them
agency and in so doing were suddenly
prepositioning agency in our brains two
systems that are in fact machine not
made of carbon at all and so this
session focuses on all of these impacts
on the ways in which there are
opportunities from computation to give
us and proper upon us agency and
empowerment the ways in which in fact
these systems can take away our agency
in our sense of the personal empowerment
and the ways in which these systems give
us room to make sense of them by giving
them a sense of agency and changing our
man-machine relationship as with all of
the sessions we've had we start by
actually having a spotlight on one of
our presidential fellows thanks to the
endowment that we have and in this case
the person they'll be introducing is
Zachary way to which I'm going to read
up a little bit of a bio about him and
then he gets to talk for a few minutes
to you about his research which is
perfectly positioned for this area
Zachary began his undergraduate career
at the University of Arizona before
transferring to UPenn where he got a BA
in mathematical economics with a minor
in classical studies his research
interests lie at the intersection of
economics psychology and
he tries to identify places and
situations in which human thought is
augmented assailed displaced by
computation and to understand the
psychological economic and social
ramifications of those boundary
interactions so he asked questions like
how will automation reshape not just who
works but how individuals find meaning
through work in his research he draws on
a range of methods including behavioral
decision science statistical models of
cognition economics and frameworks and
complex systems so you can see real
interdisciplinary thought is required in
this area as we've seen before
Zachary welcome thank you I'm thrilled
to be able to follow up on one of the
threads that was introduced in
yesterday's keynote talk and that's the
issue of attention I'll be using this
issue and a little bit of my research
about it as a foil for a more general
discussion of the relationship between
behavioral science and artificial
intelligence to do that I'll give you a
little bit of a background and some of
the things that we've learned through
behavioral science over the last 50 60
years and also talk about how they're
relevant to this conversation that we're
having about ethics and AI
so I'm really happy that several of the
other presenters have mentioned Herbert
Simon and Alan Newell because they're
also where my story starts back at the
forefront of the cognitive revolution in
the 1950s and 60s they were instrumental
in introducing the idea that computation
could be used as a way to understand
human behavior
they didn't just believe that
computation could be used to model the
human mind they actually believed that
it was a powerful metaphor for
understanding what the mind was dealing
in particular this led Herbert Simon to
develop his theory of bounded
rationality the notion that humans
because we're finite computational
agents must simplify complex problems
and use various different strategies to
make them manageable Kahneman and
Tversky in the following decades
expounded and deepened this perspective
through a number of very provocative
experiments that demonstrated precisely
the situations
in which our decision-making breaks down
throughout their research one theme
emerges which is that our deliberative
conscious decision-making faculty in
order to cope with the complexity of
life offload some of the work on to our
perceptual system and therefore just as
we fall into optical illusions we can
fall into choice illusions leading to
bias and potentially mistakes so how
does this relate to attention I'd like
to start us off with a beautiful quote
from Herbert Simon writing almost 50
years ago in a way that would describe
many of the things that we experience
today in an information-rich world the
wealth of information means a dearth of
something else the scarcity of whatever
it is that information consumes what
information consumes is rather obvious
it consumes the attention of its
recipients so building on this insight
of attention as being a scarce resource
and current work with Georg Lowenstein
and Nick shader we're using economics to
model the the the way that the brain
decides to make an allocation decision
about where we should we should focus
our attention the central premise of our
work is that it would be incredibly
difficult for us simultaneously to be
attending to something and also using
our conscious deliberation deciding
whether we should continue attention
continue focusing attention on that
object switch attention or otherwise
change our attentional strategy and so
our conscious deliberative brain
offloads this task to a non conscious
more associative process now this non
conscious more associative process needs
to reincorporate its perspective back
into deliberative judgment and it does
this by sending us informational signals
that we feel phenomenologically as
boredom curiosity and flow one of the
really amazing things that we've
uncovered is some of the neuroscience
that supports this perspective and
there's some really provocative evidence
that suggests that the same neural
mechanisms and strategies that allow
bees and bears to forage in the
wilderness allow us to for
for information on the web so where does
this leave us one thing that's really
important when we're discussing agency
is understanding what agency is and I
think very powerfully the picture that
emerges from the behavioral science can
form that question another thing that
was brought up in the keynote yesterday
was this question of what kind of
environments were constructing for
ourselves with artificial intelligence
and digital technology as we move
further from the environments that we
developed and evolved to cope with we
introduce potential strains on the way
that we make decisions on the way that
the mind functions and these have really
profound impacts on the way that we
experience our lives and the decisions
that we ultimately make I think that
this finally leaves us with a
perspective that as technologists as
policymakers as leaders we decide
everyday to me to build a world that
either works with the mind to produce
healthy cohesive and unified thought or
that works to further create conflict in
the fissures that exist naturally in the
way that our mind approaches
problem-solving and with that I thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
well that outstanding short talk by
Zachary once again reminds us how
perfect it is to have graduate student
fellowships all the work that they're
doing every one of them is unique and
perfectly situated in a precisely the
space that we're defining in this area
of inquiry so that's just lovely now
every one of our sessions has had a
panel and we've designed the whole thing
so every panel is different in format
and I really really enjoyed the long
talk format that we just had before so
this final panel is really
unconventional for us because it's a
conventional panel so get ready and
tighten your seatbelts I will leave it
to our outstanding moderator to
introduce the panelists who are all
friends of mine and real experts in the
area of agency and empowerment and I
think you're really going to enjoy it
but I do get to introduce our moderator
and I have a written bio and I'm not
gonna use it because I've known bill
logistical for many many years probably
more than a decade and
is the case that I've already said
probably five times in this how
important to me investigative journalism
is for societal discourse so bill is
actually one of my heroes he's one of
the people who I've watched doing
investigative journalism in Pittsburgh
for more than a decade he's done it at a
place called the city paper locally now
he works at the local national public
radio station but in his work what I've
seen is the ethic of actually caring
deeply to dive deep into every issue we
have in this area from inequality to
housing issues to fracking and he's the
model of what we need from our children
which is to ask the hard questions that
allow us to have proper discussion
society so with no further introduction
bill may invite you to the stage to
introduce our panel good afternoon
so I guess I'll just start by
introducing the panel we have a three
panelists coming up in no particular
order I wanted to introduce first Chad
Jenkins
Chad's a an associate professor of
computer science and engineering at the
University of Michigan's robotics
Institute he's editor in chief of ACM
transactions on human robot interaction
his fields of study and concern include
how human users can teach robots the
creation of independent living
technologies for aging populations and
making sure that the implementation of
new technologies involves broad
participation across society in order to
ensure that the impact is positive and
beneficial
Chad Jenkins
when de Wallach is a consultant ethicist
and scholar at Yale University's
interdisciplinary Center for Bioethics
he's also senior advisor at the Hastings
Institute Wendell has chaired the
centers working research group on
technology and ethics and he is co-chair
of the World Economic Forum's Global
Future Council on technology values and
policy fields of particular interest for
Wendell include drone technology his
latest book is a dangerous master how to
keep technology from slipping beyond our
control
Wendell Wallach and last but not least
from right here on Carnegie Mellon's
campus Molly Wright Steenson a designer
writer and speaker is the K&L gates
associate professor in ethics and
computational technologies and an
associate professor in Carnegie Mellon's
School of Design her accomplishments
include building the first news delivery
website at reuters way back in 1995 and
in 1996 managing Netscape the second
most hit web page on the Internet at the
time she's the author of architectural
intelligence how designers and
architects created the digital landscape
and her website is called girl wander
calm Molly right Steenson
[Applause]
so the format of this panel is for some
kind of introductory questions for each
of the panelists to kind of get things
rolling and then we'll have some time
for questions at the end about 10
minutes or so most likely I wanted to
start out by asking will go in the order
to the folks came up so so Chad um you
know you work in the field of robotics
partly this is your robotics for aging
populations which one
folks can obviously think of obviously
many uses for that particular technology
but but we're talking about agency and
empowerment what do you even see an
empowerment mean in that context to you
well I think agency and empowerment
really III said actually let me let me
first say I would want people to think
about what question do I get most asked
when I'm on campus just think about that
for a second and so right after am I on
the football team I usually get when
will I graduate and and so I'm taking
that as a compliment
you know when will I graduate but I've
actually been fortunate being computer
science and robotics for for over 25
years what we've seen in terms of the
development of the technology when I
think of my agency and empowerment as an
individual it is increased you know I
what we used to think was just Star Trek
The Next Generation are now just part of
our daily lives we take faith time we
take automated translators for granted
we're gonna see that trend continue for
robotics robotics is really the
evolution of of what personal computing
looked like and so I take for granted
that we're gonna produce those
technologies
students like the ones at CMU and
Michigan are really excited about doing
this about having this this opportunity
and they will produce greater agency in
terms of what we choose to do what we
what we want to do with ourselves and
empowerment to be able to take that on
the thing that concerns me is what are
economic incentives in order to to do
that who is going to benefit from this
as an african-american I always worry
are we increasing the economic
segregation that's happening
and so that really comes down to the
needs that we're going to address what
kind of agency that we're going to give
people across the socio-economic
spectrum and that really is you know
other than my grad students and all the
great here is they caused me really the
the needs that that we're going to
enable is what keeps me up at night okay
thank you
Wendell maybe this is maybe this is the
most basic question of all what do we
mean by agency and empower me I guess we
should just define our terms here what
do we mean by those terms and are they
related to each other in any way well I
mean we can get into the socratic thing
of taking these terms apart because the
problem is they actually means so many
different things and they mean very
different things when you're talking
about the agency and empowerment of
humans versus the agency and empowerment
of the technologies that we are are
working with but when I look at both
terms I actually think they have become
dimensions of freedom or what we have
traditionally called freedom there they
are dimensions of your degree of control
and room for initiative in your life and
perhaps what might be most helpful here
is to change the question a little bit
which is to say over the next 20 to 30
years with artificial intelligence
increase or diminish human agency and
empowerment well you can immediately
jump to so many different contexts
some people will truly be more empowered
by these tools presuming these tools to
become extensions of their will and
intention and other people may feel
totally disempowered by the same tool so
if you're a truck driver and I often use
truck drivers in this context because
there's one point seven million
long-distance truck drivers in the
United States long-haul truck drivers
and their jobs will disappear well
before the short haul truck drivers
world their jobs will disappear with
self-driving trucks
appearing long before we even have
self-driving cars on city streets and in
in large numbers other than experimental
numbers which means that in America if
this took ten years you're gonna lose
fourteen thousand truck drivers fourteen
thousand jobs for long-haul truck
drivers every month so they aren't gonna
be empowered by this technology
regardless of whether you think in the
long run that perhaps there will be more
jobs than are actually being decimated
because we're talking about the kind of
jobs that are appropriate for them so
are we really going to be able to create
14,000 new jobs every month that are
appropriate for long-haul truck drivers
along with all the new people who are
entering the markets along with other
people whose jobs have disappeared
probably not so their empowerment may
come in a very different way my my
example is how these technologies have
the potential to be very disruptive I've
often suggested that they may just take
their some eyes close down interstate
highways and sit in their cabs with
their m16s in their in their laps and
say to the government bring it on so
it's just a way of saying that we are
with a bunch of technologies right now
that are going to have very different
impacts on very different segments of
the society they may give agency to the
technologies themselves but in for many
people they will be seen as
disempowering thank you
mommy so what we're talking about again
sort of defining our terms a little bit
but we also need to talk about who makes
the decisions and and you've asked this
question I think part of your job is to
design for better agency and empowerment
in technology but whose role was this to
decide how that gets done so it's
interesting being here in in in many
ways
technologically lead conversation about
artificial intelligence I wasn't able to
attend the session just that just a
place because I was teaching but
manuela Veloso today pointed out that
there's a question of AI doing what we
expect and then there's always a
question of AI doing what it knows and
what it's trained on the question is who
defines those data sets and I think we
know well speaking of race bias or
economic bias we know well some of the
things that can go wrong when datasets
are gathered in a biased manner or when
that bias isn't taken into consideration
if you limit how data is collected and
how the scope and an of an algorithm is
created you can potentially I think
increase the harm or increase the risk
of harm in in those datasets so one
thing that I find myself thinking as as
a designer architectural and
technological historian and citizen
perhaps is that I think we need to have
other people at the table and it's
difficult when designers are not the
ones crafting the algorithms but
designers are people who frame questions
and if we refer back to herb Simon I
think that's something that he's always
understood is that the framing of the
question and framing of the problem is a
vital aspect to what what that problem
is doing and this is where citizens and
policy makers and designers and
architects and other individuals play
very important role in questions of
artificial intelligence and certainly
certainly around agency and empowerment
thank you thank you and this brings us
back again I guess to some of the issues
we were talking about with Chad how do
we get people from different levels and
parts of society involved in these
decisions they're typically being made
by folks of a particular demographic how
do we get other people involved I was I
was told that I could I could be
inflammatory and offensive and so so I
think the many many of our efforts are
focused on corporations and
you know and they're hiring rates but I
I really think it's the I think we have
failed as universities in order to train
the next generation I think what happens
is as we bring in students those
students perform they look very much
like us they produce in ways that we
expect and things that they produce they
produce products that are valuable to us
and so we want more of that and so it
creates this cycle where you were you
bring in a lot of the same types of
people over and over again and this
isn't just race this is socio-economic I
think a lot of these things break down
by zip code more than anything else
though I think what you really have to
have as an incentive for us as educators
to to provide the tools across the
populace and that incentive really isn't
there right now if we think about
federal funding from from all the
agencies that enable us to do things
that we that were to enable our work our
education you know we're incentivized to
not to produce more technical outputs
and not necessarily think about the
impact of that and what and the types of
people that we're producing just yet
it's not that it's a that it's a non
prior work it's it's completely off the
list of priorities but it is lower on
the list and so if you have that
incentive I think that is what's gonna
cause a better training of the populace
what would that just to follow up what
would that incentive look like to you or
a possible a possible inside I believe
if I think about my own experience title
9 has has played a huge role you know we
were talking about men whele below so
who may still be out here she's provided
all sorts of great mentorship throughout
my career
Jessica Hodgins who whose faculty here
at CMU she gave me my first start as a
master student my advisor is my PhD
advisor is female I think the
opportunities extended to them through
things like title 9 which essentially
says that you should have equitable
access to to education opportunities
opportunities at the university showed
that universities offer I think if that
was extended into the sciences extended
to more demographics
I think that would make a big difference
does this start maybe in in earlier
grades of school primary school grade
school and things like that too as a
faculty member I am very hesitant to
touch on K through 12 education I think
that is much bigger than I can that I
can I can take on I know as a faculty
member at a university that my incentive
is not necessarily to create a more
diverse a or diverse student body a more
diverse set of scholars my Center is to
bring in bring in federal money bringing
grant money and produce people who are
going to be capable and that the end
diversity and broader socio-economic
reach is not necessarily a part of that
okay Wendell let's let's go back to the
question essential question of agency
again are there times when it might be
good to delegate agency and what would
determine that what are the factors
there well the delegation of agency is
largely about what you want to achieve
and what your goals are and whether
those can be achieved through the
delegation of agency I think the bigger
question of course other times when one
should not be delegating a agency but I
would like us to step back a little bit
because there's a bigger question at
stake here and it's always about what
kind of world are we even trying to
create here what's their intention are
we really creating a world that will
serve the interests of the best a number
of humanity will they be happy with it
or are we largely technologists and a
few others reflecting on the societal
and ethical implications you know moving
forward with a plan that is somewhat out
of control and so I'm not so concerned
about whether we delegate agency or not
I'm more concerned about whether we
delegate agency in a way that
disempowers us and that's the
relationship between these two terms
that that comes up because there's
implication there's ramifications with
when and where we delegate agency I'm
particularly concerned about lethal
autonomous weapons because I think
they're the tip
the proverbial iceberg where we are
taking a first step toward abrogating
responsibility and delegating agency to
systems and those systems we might want
to think that they're extensions of our
own will and intention but there's no
reason to believe that they fully will
be and they become a first step in
walking down a road where at one point
we thought that there was an agent
either human or corporate that was
responsible and potentially culpable and
liable for the harms of the technologies
that we deploy and we are sort of taking
that out of the equation particularly
with autonomy particularly with
algorithms that have no transparency in
them if they are deployed in situations
where they can cause harm so it is this
never-ending cycle of whether we are
actually defusing control over our
social well-being over the development
about history in the name of actually
extending our capital our power in some
limited realms our potential for
entertainment or perhaps even better
health which becomes the mantra that's
repeated over and over again how a is
going to improve healthcare but we don't
look comprehensively at what we're
putting in place and to come back to the
question you gave Chad I think that's
the empowerment we need to give the
public we need to really find a way to
have a conversation that we've actually
failed to have over the last 20 or 30
years which is a multi stakeholder
engagement in the future we're creating
and what our intentions are what our
goals are what values we actually want
to maximize with this Wendell it's to
follow but this room this requires sort
of changing how we make decisions as a
society because right now decisions on
many things are being made by again a
relatively small group of really
empowered people sort of the oligarchy
if you will that makes these decisions
corporate and government and think
like that people talk about the crisis
of democracy when these issues is is a I
just in some sense these questions about
AI a reflection of that larger problem I
I think that's a really well put
question I want to sort of leave it more
of it as a question rather than that I'm
going to give an answer but I think the
crisis of democracy is it's not clear
how much democracy we have anymore
whether we've abrogated authority to
those who control capital and it's not
those who control capital it's just the
idea that what's important is the
increase in capital versus other metrics
if we could use so some Jeff Sachs may
even talk about this afterwards because
he's one of the leaders in looking at at
potential happiness metrics that could
be brought into play but the crisis is
that we have bought into different
policies that increase capital growth
but don't look at how its distributed
whether it's helping all the members of
the society and that are more focused on
what can increase capital growth than
what leads to overall welfare overall
benefit to the society as a whole so I
think in a certain sense AI in that
context and please understand I'm not a
Luddite I'm thrilled by some of the some
of the wonderful things that AI will
produce for us but AI becomes the tool
of inattention to refer back to our
first speaker there was something called
the Frankfurt School which is a group of
Marxists in the 1930s and they were they
were looking at what was the function of
culture in a capitalist society and they
argued that the function of culture was
to woo us into unconsciousness well we
are now being manipulated by our
dopamine and by companies that have
understood how to manipulate our
attitudes through getting these dopamine
responses so in that sense
ai becomes a potential tool for the
dismantling of democracy and then in in
that regard yes it is part of the crisis
of democracy Molly yeah okay add to that
that there's a question of what we're
what gets exchanged right so worker
productivity could be exchanged on one
hand for a greater forms of manipulation
or control or monitoring you could see
that with drive with long-haul truckers
and their increasing symbiosis with the
trucking cab and these weird kind of
intermediate steps or the Walmart worker
who's following voice picking cues right
it's kind of a strange it's it's JCR
Licklider who coined the term human man
computer symbiosis in 1960 but we
achieve it now in some pretty strange
hybrid ways I mean it's just that we're
often losing sight of the actual
trade-off because we are so focused on
the benefit this morning Eleanor Rosch
was talking about questions of literacy
and fluency and before I came to
Carnegie Mellon I was a journalism
professor at the University of
wisconsin-madison a lot of my journalism
professor friends in the internet space
are now you know not surprisingly
working on these questions of bias fake
news algorithms and ethics and it
becomes difficult to envision a media
fluency immediate literacy or even a you
know not to mention a fluency in this
kind of world where our very actions
seem to not make a lot of sense to us so
there's a long way to go I think before
we're able to get there I was going to
ask question from Molly Wendel spoke
about the need for having having a
discussion obviously this is a
discussion that many of our fellow
citizens are not having at this point
what do we need to do to increase
literacy on things like AI agency and
empowerment I think that we may be
beginning to have some of these
discussions right now
one thing that I think is helpful is to
remember that AI is old we've talked
about it throughout the sessions I've
been a part of as though it's quite new
but in many ways it's not the term was
coined in 1955 by some accounts it's
much older than that
Pamela McCord ik says it goes back to
the first century AD in Egypt but these
notions are already some 60 years old
and even the terminology that we use the
the framing of the research is still
going back to the early to mid 1950s I
don't mean to slow people down from its
urgency but I think that if we remember
that we've been making these decisions
for a long time that there are AI
winters of failures of funding and
failures of progress it's important to
keep those in mind I think it's also
vital to remember that AI has always had
its agenda pushed by the Department of
Defense the you know the the way that we
think of AI was the infant information
processing technologies office in the
60s with people like Licklider or the
office of naval research and that's
Marvin Zdenek off a couple of people
defined what the AI research agenda was
it's broader now that it's
commercialized and that we are actually
seeing successes where before we were
limited by capabilities of storage or
processing but I think it's vital to
remember what framed these questions to
begin with and remember that those same
questions and those same I guess
tendencies might be framing the
discussion right now in ways that we
don't see if I could follow up follow up
on that so so it is you know III think
it's great that you're bringing up the
the history of AI coming from the
Department of Defense where the
incentive was an existential threat to
the United States what's different now
is a lot of these companies that we're
talking about are and a lot of the
things that we're seeing are venture
capital based right the bottom line is
basically how do we get more money when
our students come in and they're tough
and are
who are trained to be versed in AI
computer vision machine learning
robotics they're asking themselves what
company can I go to what start up from
there what startup can I can i generate
the incentive is really you you have
sort of depending on who you are of
vicious or a virtuous cycle of
investment than opportunity than
technology and then and then more
investment and a short time frame right
VC is a three-year five-year timeframe
and Wendell is talking about the 20 to
30 year question right and and and and I
think what comes out of that is if
you're looking further along right if
you're the Department of Defense and
you're looking at this from the 1940s
perspective you're thinking very far out
you know because the the existence of
the country is really what you're what
you're thinking about if you're thinking
about well how do I make my investors
happy then you're going to think very
short-term and that was that's what
leads us in terms of in terms of needs
and not to necessarily think about the
needs that are going to be down the road
that we have to think about our aging
population education infrastructure it
leads us to think about what can I sell
and get out to people quickly and be
able to and think about really about how
can I be more profitable at a monetary
short term as opposed to what the needs
may be you know who's gonna be
unemployed we don't necessarily think
about that until until that effect hits
us if we could maybe move to a couple
questions from the audience now I have
one here and whoever feels interested to
take it um what are problems that could
evolve from not only transferring agency
from ourselves to AI decision-makers but
also blame does anyone see any way to
discuss that or issues with that
particular problem I have opinions on
that I I think what to me were the where
the rubber hits the road is insurance
will somebody be willing to insure a
robot going out whether it be car you
know robot that delivers snacks in a
hospital or anything like that I you
know it's I think that you know that's
that is where blame gets decided who's
gonna pay the penalty
for when things go wrong and I have no
idea how to how to address that um any
other thoughts there no uh how about
about this one what are some ways that
algorithmic systems could empower we
usually speak about them disempowering
people could empower disadvantaged
groups in society presumably depending
on who writes those algorithms right
does anyone we dress that no I think
this is a very important area and I'm
I've been involved in in these
conferences actually we're just gonna
have the second one at the UN in Geneva
on on AI for good and one of the really
important things we're considering is
how a I might actually help some of the
poorer nations of the world leapfrog and
and move into the future and in fact
there's a city in Africa that I don't
know whether it's actually been
announced or not that's being that's
looked at as a tough city for the wired
city that it will be the the first smart
city in in the world and many of the
other African countries are looking at
but so that's a obviously getting going
to take AI to do that now whether that's
really feasible or functional or whether
you can ensure the security of a smart
city those are all kinds of secondary
and tertiary questions but another area
in which it can make a great deal of
difference difference is if we start
even just simply putting deep learning
algorithms on some of the diseases that
are diseases of a poor people and come
up with more efficient methods of
attending to those so most people don't
know what system iosef is but it's
actually a disease which is is a disease
that people in poor countries get I
think it's one of the greatest killers
in the world now that's not a disease
that's just gonna be dealt with in terms
of AR but AI in combination with
sanitary methods and with biotechnology
ISM with refrigeration
and clean water techniques I mean AI is
not alone in this game I think we all
understand we are in the midst of an
inflection point of history whether
these tremendous numbers of Technology
coming down the pike and they're going
to interact in different ways but it's
clear that AI is the amplifier and that
AI has the capacity to bring levels of
efficiency into the utilization of these
resources that won't be there without a
but it's but it's a question obviously
of where do we choose to apply our
efforts in you know what problems do we
point a eye toward in other words right
decisions are made that way and also
whether we're going to what shall I say
which of our values were willing to
lower in order to get the benefits of AI
so one of the big issues around health
care is a conglomeration of data if we
glamour ate all data then we would have
a situation where we might actually come
up with some unique relationships within
that data that lead us to solving some
diseases even of small groups of people
but to do that we have to conglomerate
the data and to conglomerate the data we
undermine privacy concerns we we move
into this whole realm of what kinds of
data protection do people have so we're
in this kind of strange trade-off period
again in terms of which values are we
going to consider primary for the next
decade or two in which are we willing to
weaken in the same way as we have
weakened privacy in this country over
the last couple of days it up over the
last couple decades excuse me it might
happen but I think to that point it's
also easy to fall into false dichotomies
and I I don't I know that's not where
you're going but someone like Daniel
Salaf will point out for instance that
if you have nothing to hide you have
nothing to fear is a false dichotomy
fine you know you open your curtains
drop your pants show me what's in your
in
you know those are those are trade offs
we're not going to make but I think it's
important to ponder what those trade
offs are and make visible to people what
that actually costs one thing that's
been shocking about the network effects
of Cambridge analytic for a lot of
people is that they never had pondered
that that might have been a possibility
and I know earlier we were talking about
in terms of service agreements sure we
may have agreed but but the fact is it's
in the best interest of a lot of
different actors for those trade offs to
not be visible I think this was this
interesting question with privacy I'm
not taking the stance of privacy is
above all else I do think there are real
questions about whether we should be
lowering our privacy standards in order
to conglomerate data that may facilitate
the overall well-being of large numbers
of people
I think there's questions about whether
we should be having a conversation about
self-driving cars as to whether even if
they aren't ready for primetime and may
kill people that an attentive driver
would not kill whether if indeed and
this has not been proven it's been
planed but it's far from proven if
indeed they will cause that many less
accidents that maybe we should be
prepared to take on a few deaths that
will be caused by self-driving cars than
an attentive driver would not cause now
that's just a way of saying that ethics
it's not some hardcore thing that cannot
evolve and change with the technologies
I think the fear only is that it will
in a manner that disempowers people not
empowers them but speaking speaking this
I think as part of the conversation
really a and who can be a part of it
where this technology would go what we
choose to focus on really is still
driven by markets market potential where
that investment can be made I'm sure
that my cousins and my family down in
Houston
love to think about these things they
don't we're really it's really sheltered
and sort of these small bubbles where we
have the agency and empowerment to think
about it but really that's um
that that I I just worry that of these
short-term economic financial gains are
really what's gonna drive these
questions more than anything else okay I
think we're about ready to wrap things
up here we're coming in in our time well
any last words from anyone if not
multiple thankfully we gotta say one
last word about Carnegie Mellon
University one of the things that I have
been crying out about for quite a number
of years now is that universities give
all kinds of lip service is a need for
interdisciplinary scholarship I like to
say transdisciplinary scholarship
because I think we need more than
interdisciplinary scholars and yet there
is seldom a reward system in any of the
universities for that and it looks like
I'm wrong it looks like Carnegie Mellon
University is actually rewarding both
faculty and some of their graduate
students for being transfers many
scholars
okay well thanks thanks everyone for for
attending and thanks once again to Chad
Jenkins Jenkins Fuchs
Wendell Wallach and Molly right Steenson
don't hand it back over deal with a
wonderful final conclusion panel for us
to have I think the panel very much and
you'll notice that agency and
empowerment turned into a question of
trust and surveillance as well so these
are all issues that cannot be divorced
from one another well it's my honor and
pleasure to introduce the final speaker
of the entire conference so no pressure
at all Jeff and originally I thought I
had to introduce him really slowly
because they were gonna set up a podium
but that's not happening after all so I
can actually speak quickly so be warned
I will be done as quickly as I start so
I've been enjoying reading the work of
Jeff Sachs he's director of the
sustainable he's director of the Center
for sustainable development at Columbia
University and University professor he
has served as a director of the Earth
Institute he served a special adviser to
the United Nations Secretary General
Antonio Guterres on the sustainable
development goals which you heard about
multiple times today from Anya from me
earlier and and soon from Jeff and he's
director of the United Nations
sustainable development Solutions
Network he has a prolific writing and
many many books but two are very
relevant in a very recent time so I
wanna mention their names in full one is
called the age of sustainable
development and one is called building
the new American economy so without
further ado I invite Jeff to stage to
lead us on a tour of his thoughts on
this very important subject
[Applause]
thank you very much what a great
conference and what a wonderful panel
that was touching on many of the themes
that I'd like to conclude with I'm last
and least equipped to talk about the
technical side of AI but I hope I can
add some useful ideas about the economic
implications and I think it's already
clear but it's also true as is surmise
that the digital revolution generally an
AI specifically will have enormous
economic implications and these are
already underway but especially if we
take the broader definition of the
digital revolution we're already seeing
massive shifts in income distribution
massive changes in the kinds of jobs in
the economy and of course there's a lot
more to come and I want to talk about
those points there are six that I want
to make briefly first we have had a long
200 years of machines substituting for
labor this is fundamental to the era of
modern economic growth which is about
200 years old it is an ongoing and very
real process it has a certain logic it
has gone from replacing arduous physical
labor primarily and repetitive work and
as the machines get smarter and better
of course it replaces more and more
cognitive activity and more contextual
work so there has been a transformative
logic through several waves of what
economists call general purpose
technologies from the steam engine
through the internal combustion engine
electrification and the digital
revolution which I would put as roughly
75 years old at this point though sir
accelerating this revolution more than
all the others is science and
engineering based and it's certainly
raising the returns to research and
development and more than any of the
other technologies has fostered a highly
trained stem based professional class
which is already transforming the
economy fundamentally national income
has been shifting for a century away
from raw labour or basic unskilled
physical labor to capital the main kind
of capital is human capital so the main
kind of transformation that has been
underway has been a shift from basic
labor to trained higher educated labor
when we measure the overall national
income distribution and we talk about
labor income we miss that basic
transformation because there is a block
of income which we call compensation to
work and that for a long time remained
roughly unchanged at about 65 to 70
percent of the economy but within that
broad category was a profound
transformation from unskilled labor
mainly agricultural to professional
labor and labor that was earning the
returns to education work does not get
replaced when it's substituted by
machines so a question was asked will
there be the same number of jobs after
autonomous trucks replaced drivers
throughout the last 200 years that's
never been the case actually what has
been the case is that as employment has
been replaced by machines a significant
part of the effect has been a rise of
non work time in society we benefit from
machines because we like more leisure
time if we have because of the modern
age we have retirement time with
was a concept that did not exist for
society before really the last century
we have of course a prolonged period of
schooling for all of society in a very
long period of schooling for part of
society so what has happened in the
Machine replacing labor phenomenon of
the last two centuries is a profound
decline of actual work hours and I'll
make a point about that in in just a
moment quantitatively but what it means
is we should not only ask the question
where will the new jobs come from but
also ask the question how can we share
the benefits of more leisure time that
will come from smarter and smarter
machines and robots in an equitable way
within a generation across countries and
over time fifth point is there is a
widening of income inequality already
underway propelled by the advancing
technologies of course the United States
has the widest gap between rich and poor
then we have had in at least a century
we have unprecedented income inequality
part of that is politics a significant
part of that is a market phenomenon and
the main market phenomenon is how
changing technology differentially
impinges higher skilled and lower
skilled workers and that has a lot to do
with what kind of family one grows up in
all of the evidence shows that the u.s.
is increasingly a tract society if you
grow up in a household where the parents
or a single parent raising the children
even more likely does not have a college
degree
the chances of young person finishing a
bachelor's degree or more is very low
the chances that that young person will
experience real hardship in the labor
market is quite high on the other hand
children growing up in affluent families
have a very high probability of
attaining affluence themselves
especially through the ability to
complete a four-year college degree or
more and the final point that I'll come
back to is we need a whole new set of
public policies to address this
technology just as we have always
required fundamentally new social
socio-political policies every time we
have a major wave of technology in this
sense this is nothing new
qualitatively the Industrial Revolution
transformed Society in fundamental ways
we are also transforming society again
in fundamental ways I should have said
right at the beginning
AI and the digital revolution offers
solutions to problems and raises
productivity in principle this means
that it can be a net and I would say
profound benefit for society but there
is nothing in any technology that
guarantees that that is the case because
technologies have differential impacts
across income classes across different
parts of society they can always be used
malevolently as well as been efficiently
and there is no reason ever to believe
that the market outcomes of even a
dramatically positive productivity
enhancing technology will benefit
everybody or even necessarily a majority
of society the benefits are highly
distributed often quite complex and
often with huge numbers of losers so
what we see today in the labor market is
a declining share of national income
going to labor and this is one graph a
smooth moving average of that jagged
business cycle affected
curve but we see in the aggregate that
the share of income going to labor has
dropped from roughly 2/3 in 1930 to
about 56% today but even that shift as I
mentioned masks a much much larger shift
which is that within the category labor
the amount of income accruing to lower
skilled workers has plummeted and the
amount of earnings going to higher
skilled workers has increased
mechanization or automation or now
digitization of jobs has proceeded
systematically according to the - now
very widely recognized dimensions what
is the level of expertise and I would
say cognitive expertise needed in the
tasks and what is the predictability of
the workflow and basically mechanization
worked for basic tasks that were highly
predictable and farm mechanization was
among the very first of course to
experience dramatic transformations the
goods-producing sector of the economy
which is agriculture mining construction
and manufacturing has been the easiest
to automate and a part of that of course
has been the brilliance of the Henry
Ford's and the Taylor's of redesigning
workflow precisely so that it could be
machine operated so it's not as if the
technologies came fully packaged the
workflow itself can be redesigned and
that of course is happening and all the
rest of the sectors of the economy as
well but other sectors relatively low
skilled personal services cannot be
smacking eyes so easily because workflow
predictability is low if you take this
logic the next sector to go in very
broad automation is business services
and this is exactly what's underway
right now wholesale and
retail trade transport and warehousing
finance this is all now with artificial
intelligence subject to mass
mechanization and that's a very
substantial part of the labor force in
fact here is a snapshot in 1900 in the
United States agricultural workers were
36% of the labor force now they're one
percent a lot of farmers lost their jobs
and farmers children left the farms and
went to the cities has this uh net been
a good process absolutely this is the
biggest decline of arduous back-breaking
labor imaginable and this is what every
country in the world yearns for we
produce all the food for the United
States and some for the rest of the
world with less than 1% of our labor
force precisely because of the power of
smart machines and they're getting
smarter and smarter
I met a farmer recently who said I asked
what he does he said I don't farm at all
anymore but I still like to sit on the
tractor while it drives itself around my
farm he said I sit backwards I read a
book I see where I'm going from but the
tractor does everything including of
course the precision deposition of
fertilizers and insecticides satellite
mediated so production workers which is
mainly in this account mining
construction and manufacturing decline
from 24% of the labor force to 14% today
those jobs are not coming back the whole
idea and this is a steel town of course
everybody knows that this is true Trump
saying I'm going to bring these jobs
back the jobs are not coming back
because there are fewer and fewer jobs
in the goods-producing sector and these
will continue to decline and the jobs
that remain are mainly design R&D higher
tech jobs they're not assembly jobs
which have not gone to China and Mexico
primarily they've gone to the machines
now that tend to
the processes trade transport and
administration which I called the
business services sector in the earlier
slide went from 16 percent of the labor
force to 28 percent that's the one
that's going to get hit next because
ecommerce autonomous trucking
warehousing all of this is going to mean
that we're not going to go to shops the
same way here we're going to go to shops
to have a look but not to buy we're
going to have a dramatic drop of
employment in that sector and I would
guess that that one is the the next to
go other services are mainly personal
services and then professional is health
education research and development and
government that's the transformation of
society from 4% of the labor force in
1904 percent to 39 percent today now of
course we have become to societies in
this country those who have a college
degree in above and those who don't and
we live in two completely different ways
one with rising incomes and living
standards and the other with falling
incomes and declining living standards
and that is to a very significant extent
the result of technology but it's also
the result of our politics which is that
the ones on the top haven't give to them
about the ones that are falling behind
so it's always a combination of the
market forces and then how they're
mediated through politics and since our
politics are money driven these days and
the money is at the top and I mean the
1% of the 1% of the 1% the few
billionaires who increasingly run our
politics in Washington they are giving
themselves tax cuts and cutting benefits
for those who are losing their jobs and
seeing a declining labor demand at the
bottom of the income distribution you
take a case like the assembly line in
you
in an auto plant now where you won't see
a worker in the hole in the whole plant
floor this is what it looks like in
terms of the share of labor
it went from 70% of value added in in
automotive in vehicle production 70% in
1987 so just 30 years ago to 45% today
and that is what is happening
society-wide but sector by sector
differentially depending on how
susceptible to digitisation
the sector is and of course this shows
up in the change of the income
distribution by education high education
here is College and above medium is some
college through high school and low is
below a high school diploma and you see
that basically low-income workers have
not budged in there this case is a real
mean earnings in median wage has
declined actually but this mean earnings
has remained unchanged now for more than
four decades at the bottom while those
of us lucky to have college degrees and
above we've had an affluence really
amazing during this whole period and
that's why her society feels in such
different different conditions now as I
mentioned one of the primary changes
that comes is the way we live our lives
in terms of time allocation and this I
think is extremely important maybe
especially for Americans to understand
what smart machines allow us to do is
take a little time off I have to say it
what we do we call it work but it's
really quite pleasant
and we don't break a sweat doing it
there's always plenty of food around
wonderful company if we weren't paid to
do it we'd come to do it anyway because
it's a really pleasant to be together
and to be talking about such things but
we do get paid little strange I
shouldn't say it but in any event we
also take real non paid leisure time
more and more and our society has really
transformed in a hugely beneficial way
compared to where it was a hundred years
ago so in 1900 by my rough calculation
the average hours of work per day seven
days a week was seven point eight hours
a day there was basically no vacation
time and no weekend time except for
going to church there was work around
the house there was work on the farm
very long days in the factories today
according to the BLS time studies time
allocation studies the average American
adult above the age of 16 works three
hours 3.1 eight hours or basically three
hours 20 minutes a day that's the
average for adults in the United States
it's rather remarkable actually that out
of three hours twenty minutes we get
actually it's three hours of 14 minutes
excuse me we're getting 60,000 dollars
per person per year that's how
productive our smart machines are now
what are we doing with the rest of the
time going to school time off family
leave vacation time and retirement time
now it turns out that Americans work
much more than our European counterparts
and that's not because they can't find
jobs it's because in Europe they're
smart they take six weeks vacation try
to find a Swede in July
you used to say that in August but now
you can't find them in July or August
because what they're doing is living a
life of affluence intelligently right
now in Germany the average work time is
about 1300 hours a year in the United
States 1700 hours per year that's 400
hours more on average in the US that's
10 weeks of 40-hour workweek more
working than in Europe in the u.s. we
don't have one day of federally
guaranteed vacate paid vacation time in
Europe usually it's 25 to 30 days of
nationally guaranteed vacation times so
this is one of the things that smart
machines could do if we were properly
motivated every job could be a decent
job with guaranteed paid leave
guaranteed maternal leave or parental
leave more vacation time more leisure
time more time for training and so forth
so let me conclude with a few policy
implications this again is on the
economic side I haven't really said
anything useful about this surveillance
the privacy and so forth which is the
ethics of a I designed the
interpretability of AI programs the
ethical responsibilities of code and so
on this we had wonderful discussion in
the last two days and I do not have
either absolute or comparative advantage
to weigh in on that but on the economic
side let me mention five quick points in
conclusion first of course with every
wave of general purpose technology we've
had to revamp the education system and
it's no different now what should be the
training what should children learn to
be effective citizens to be able to both
understand the technologies and live
productively
that doesn't mean everyone should be
trained to be a coder it may mean the
opposite of machines end up doing all
the coding in the future it may mean
other things that need to be learned but
we do need new training for the kinds of
employment in the future
second and a fundamental point we need
income redistribution our country has
lost the drift basically since 1981
January 20th 10 a.m. when Ronald Reagan
became president because that was the
end of the concept that you redistribute
income to share the benefits in a
affluent society we forgot that it's the
most not the most basic the most basic
economic function is to produce things
the second most basic is to redistribute
them because the civilized society does
both we stop the redistribution the only
rule we know is cut taxes for the rich
and this is killing our society right
now because we're becoming so divided
that we can't function we have rising
life expectancy of the rich we have
actually now falling life expectancy
sharply of the bottom of the high school
and below population and on average it's
so bad that our life expectancy
nationally has declined two years in a
row can you imagine with all the
technology all the know-how all the
advances we have declining life
expectancy in this country of course
that's not a technological phenomenon so
social catastrophe it's a population
health crisis in this country that we
don't function that we don't fashion but
it's basically because so much of the
population is left to their own devices
in the face of these very adverse and
difficult shifts a third point is share
leisure which is we should join the rest
of the civilized high-income world all
of which have guaranteed vacation
I'm paid leave family leave we need
everybody to be able to enjoy dignified
lives at a 20 trillion dollar national
economy unprecedented wealth we could do
that easily not only could we do it
easily
Canada does it the UK does it Sweden
does it Germany does it we could all do
it but we choose not to so far so this
is a third point fourth is as was
mentioned yesterday in the wonderful
talk
from the Microsoft head of Microsoft
Research we should be looking for
machine human complementarities because
that's pure win-win that doesn't replace
jobs that enhances our capacities and
but we should think hard about what
those mean humanity doesn't have too
many cognitive advantages over machines
or won't soon we've lost most of those
if you can create the world's greatest
chess player in history and four hours
of self play we know that a lot is not
far behind in terms of cognitive
capacities I'm sure the best economists
50 10 years from now are going to be
robots because they can read the
journals better and they can cipher
decipher all of the real-time economic
indicators much better than economists
ever could do so what is our advantage
we definitely have we probably have
certainly our comparative advantage and
I think it will remain our absolute
advantage is to be human beings so that
means that maybe we should be training
for the humanities maybe we should be
training for the things that really are
not necessarily trying to run
cognitively ahead of the machines but
trying to enhance the decency of life
the pleasures of life the appeals to our
human nature
flawed as it may be our artistic and
human side those are the logical
complementarities to smart machines and
the fifth point and I'll conclude here
is that unlike many aspects of a market
economy the ownership of intellectual
property is more of a choice than it may
appear to be the patent system had to be
invented in a way that's different from
the prices of commodities and the reason
is that the patent system is handling a
very strange category of economic good
and that is what economists call a non
rival good ideas are non rival goods
they can be shared widely in fact for
most ideas it's good if they're shared
widely or I mean most true scientific
ideas and that's why science in general
is not to be patented technologies yes
but in inventions but science basically
in principle not to be patented why do
we have a patent system that gives an
artificial monopoly to the ownership of
a freely replicable non-rival commodity
well the answer is of course to give
incentives for research and development
and the patent system plays a very
important role in this but it is what
economics calls the second best option
there's nothing ideal about the patent
system it creates artificial monopolies
it creates power
it creates undue influence that power
can easily last beyond the patent
expiration as well if you build up
Network externalities or other
advantages and we know that there are
other ways to incentivize the production
of intellectual knowledge this
University's name of course reflects one
of the primary ways mr. Carnegie who
invented modern philanthropy
and giving rather than demanding rewards
is an important way we know that open
source creation of intellectual property
can play a huge role and in our country
until very recently from Vannevar Bush's
astoundingly smart 1945 book on the
science the endless frontier which was I
didn't realize it which was formally at
least the response to an astoundingly
smart letter from FDR to Vannevar Bush
in the fall of 1944 asking an
astoundingly unusual question the
president asked Bush how do we make all
this secret technology that we've
developed during the war available for
civilian use whereas almost any leader
would have written to the science
advisor to ask how do we keep it secret
after the war ends FDR who was our
greatest president asked the right
question how do we make it available for
human well-being and Vannevar Bush gave
an astoundingly good answer and said we
should invest large-scale federal money
in producing science and technology we
should invent what became NSF what
became NIH what became federal grants
for kids to go on to university because
Bush noted there are going to be a lot
of smart kids in poor families that will
be the geniuses of the future we ought
to help them well we have forgotten all
of that knowledge by the way recently
because we're privatizing everything in
this country at the behest of the Koch
brothers and the I don't know what you
call it but the fantasy world of Donald
Trump so we're going in the wrong
direction the reason this is relevant
for IP is we don't have to choose to
have a patent lead knowledge-based world
or a patent only knowledge-based world
we can have an
open-source open licensed extended
knowledge non monopolized world as long
as we as a society invest a lot more of
our public funds that's a real trade-off
I hope and believe that we should go
that way
the idea that our five big tech
companies I looked just a few minutes
ago their combined net worth of Apple
Google Facebook Microsoft and Amazon is
three point four trillion dollars right
now and as we speak and Zuckerberg is
explaining the sins of Facebook to the
US Congress Facebook is worth half a
billion dollars for what for what well
for being able to aggregate our private
data and sell it to advertisers but
that's really not a very justified
social use and there's no reason why it
should be worth half a trillion dollars
I think I said half a billion half a
trillion dollars and so either it should
all be taxed away and put into the NSF's
endowment and
I just thought of that proposal but it's
a good one I think the rest of the world
is going to do it if we don't do it
already the EU was saying we're gonna
put a revenue tax on so we ought to tax
Facebook up to there because it's not
providing any social good based on this
monopoly of its portal and its access to
our private data in fact it provided
such a massive bad that it has created
one of the biggest to help create one of
the biggest disasters our country has
faced and we could recapture that
revenue and help make open-source
ownership available of course all the
other I P issues as well I just
mentioned them privacy oversight
intelligibility democratic governance
these are themes that this wonderful
conference has taken on and we've heard
a great deal of wisdom about it
I want to thank Carnegie Mellon for
hosting us thank you very much well I
want to thank Jeff Sachs again one of
the things you hope for in the
conference is some good strong value
alignment and what I want to thank him
for specifically is for saying a whole
mess of things that most of us usually
are too afraid to say on stage so that's
an outstanding set of value alignment
procedures that we just underwent which
I appreciate greatly I also want to
thank all of you the audience for making
this a vibrant and wonderful conference
and there's probably many speeches you
heard during this conference that you're
gonna want to share with your colleagues
your friends and your family and so the
good news is that the Carnegie Mellon
website for this conference is going to
live on it's gonna be archival we have
been video recording everything as you
can see that by that giant pan tilt head
in the middle of the room and everything
will be edited and online in the next
few weeks so that you can access it and
so that you can share it with your
friends and we wanted to make sure to
thank again our speakers and moderators
and panelists who really made this such
a wonderful event we want to make sure
to thank we'd like
have you helped us thank the amazing
staff who've made all of this possible
for people in particular for people that
we wanted to make sure to sort of single
out Kate Walter Sarah college Kati
Szymanski and Abby Watson have really
just made our lives much easier over the
last few months as this has all come
together into this absolutely
astonishing event we also want to make
sure to again thank Kay no gates for
their incredible generosity and
foresight in recognizing the importance
of these issues as we move forward and
enabling Carnegie Mellon to really
partner with them to lead the way in
trying to have these critical
conversations around ethics and AI and
of course thanks to all of you for
coming out over the last two days to
join us and we look for